hey everyone it's sarah the registered
nurse orion calm and in this video i
want to show you how to check the
brachioradialis deep tendon reflex so
let me show you how it's done okay we're
going to check the brachioradialis deep
tendon and this is checking c5 to c6
this can be one of the most difficult
tendons to find because it's not as
pronounced as the other tendon so what
you want to do is you want to find the
radial styloid process which is the
nodule on the wrist and go about two to
three centimeters above that have the
patient turn where their thumbs up word
relaxing the Florham resting it on their
leg we're going to right above that and
what we're looking for is for the hand
to sup innate which the palm will turn
out upward and you will see a little bit
of flexion in the forearm okay you
notice that right there okay so that is
how you check that deep tendon reflex
now check out my other videos on how to
check the other for deep tendon reflexes
and consider subscribing to this YouTube
channel